[Music]
How many times have you received a
compliment and later doubted whether or not
it was truly sincere?
It's always good to assume that people have
good intentions, but the sad reality is that
this isn't always the case.
Sometimes, people are just pretending to be
nice to us, and it's a point to know the telltale
signs of this behavior.
Are you wondering whether or not the people
around you are genuinely kind?
Here are 10 signs of fake nice people.
Humble bragging; humble bragging is a relatively
new term, but it's been around for ages.
This is when people exhibit false modesty.
They pretend to downplay their own accomplishments
while sully bragging about them at the same
time.
An example would be someone who says "I hate
being beautiful because people flirt with
me all the time".
According to psychological studies, it's actually
better if you go ahead and fully brag in these
situations, people like genuine bragging way
more than humble bragging.
Passive-aggressive behavior; you'd be surprised
how easy it is for some people to be extremely
aggressive while maintaining a guise of positive
and nice behavior.
This is known as "passive-aggressive behavior"
and it's one of the big signs of a fake nice
person.
According to research, this behavior is common
with people who have suppressed their rage
and want to maintain civility and sophistication.
When they do let their anger out however,
they can only do so by being passive-aggressive.
For example, someone might give you a compliment
but it seems rather sarcastic and backhanded.
Ghosting; another big sign of fake nice people
is ghosting.
This is when people completely fall off the
radar, refusing to answer your calls or reply
to your text.
Ghosting often occurs right after the relationship
is seemingly going pretty well.
The other person might even seem nice and
polite, then all of a sudden, they completely
cut you out of their lives.
At this point, it becomes obvious that their
nice behavior was just a big act.
Crocodile tears; the phrase "crocodile tears"
is used to describe people who fake emotions;
usually, sadness or remorse.
We see it all the time with politicians and
well-known public figures.
So, how do you spot crocodile tears?
Research has shown that people faking emotions
like remorse and sadness tend to exaggerate
these emotions.
They also show a wide range of different emotions
which don't always make sense.
For example, they might switch suddenly from
being sad to being hopeful.
How to spot a fake smile; fake nice people
are obviously very likely to show off a fake
smile.
But how do you tell the difference between
their smiles and real smiles from genuine
happy and nice people?
According to psychologists, real smiles almost
always use more facial muscles.
Specifically, you should be on the lookout
for wrinkles around the eyes.
These are key signs of a real smile.
Fake nice people can't listen; genuinely nice
people are always ready to lend an ear.
No matter what you're going through, they
can sit and listen to what you have to say.
Fake nice people might have a hard time doing
this however because they're usually very
self-centered people.
To put it simply, it's all about them.
Fake nice people might act the part, but they'll
try their best to sway the conversation towards
topics that involved them, not you.
For example, you might be explaining struggles
you have at school or work, and then someone
cuts in and starts giving you a long story
about their personal experiences in that area.
They always seem to want something; there's
usually a reason behind why fake nice people
are acting so kind and considerate.
In most cases, it's because they want something
from you.
This might not be immediately obvious, but
eventually they'll start slowly, steering
the conversation to their needs and desires.
Usually, they'll ask you to do something or
you'll discover that you have something they
want.
They're only nice to people who have power;
another big sign of a fake nice person is
that they only act in a positive way towards
those with power.
It's always good to judge people based on
how they treat people who are less fortunate
or less powerful than themselves.
If their nice behavior seems directed solely
towards those with power, then that nice behavior
probably isn't genuine.
They like to gossip and criticize others;
it's always easy to laugh at other peoples
expense, and you might even be fooled into
thinking that nice people do this as well.
But, if someone is bringing other people down
in an effort to get close to you, then you
know that deep inside they're not very nice
people.
Fake nice people love to gossip and they might
do so in a way that seems nice.
They might act with a false sense of concern
over other people's misfortune.
For example, they might talk about someone
else's substance issues with a gossipy and
unsympathetic tone, while pretending to be
concerned.
Sometimes, it's hard to spot this behavior,
but it's a big sign of fake niceness.
Fake nice people are actually pretty rare;
although there are many signs of fake nice
people, they're actually not very common.
For the most part, when someone is acting
nice towards you, they really mean it.
In fact, people have a tendency to view themselves
as less likeable than others see them.
Fake nice people do exist, but people probably
like you a lot more than you think.
That's why it's always a good idea to assume
the best in people, because you might be irrationally
fearing the worst.
Do you have any experiences with fake nice
people?
Let us know in the comments below.
Be sure to Subscribe to our Channel and watch
our videos on topics like depression or anxiety.